[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
to control the truth the concepts
of right and wrong
for everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
i'm an
[Music]
it's
idiot
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and so manly
and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me super powers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
now
listen to me billy the fate of the world
depends
[Music]
this is very personal billy
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was the signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is today
[Music]
will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family
go fight for the world
right now
i just threw a truck at a dragon i
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of thieves
and when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need food give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right i know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's an owl there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
i'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies i
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
[Music]
johannesburg
it's time for some change do you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
[Music]
we need to find the person who took that
case
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia job the twins yeah no sure
they're twins get off the train
you stab me
i would never stop coming for you what
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop sounds so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
i said yes
there's this soulless psychotic leader
with the largest criminal organization
on the planet shoved right inside
[Music]
maybe there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i i gotta get off the string
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
wait up wait up
what do you do with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good that is what you make meredith dead
i pick up garbage for a living about the
same thing smeared and cleaned up the
streets
you mind your business on my mind i
don't believe you
are you okay
i'm cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop caring
and i stopped caring a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
hey old man
try this
[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in this guy
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer calls you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being the naval aviator
absolutely
[Music]
the whole world's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown it's
good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you gonna find out about your
wingman cruising at two thousand feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows i might get a peek at who he
really is
north koreans came pouring over the 38th
parallel
our guys need help
and we're up
we knew this day might come and it
doesn't make it any easier
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
mistakes get us killed
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quickly
die even
[Music]
this one can't always do what you're
told
if i did i wouldn't be here
the real battle in all of life
being someone that people can count on
show off that was pretty good it's good
[Music]
good friends
[Music]
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world and my entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
[Music]
when i wake up
[Music]
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did mom shoot someone's face this little
bump right here that's you i still miss
her every day
[Music]
devil
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lies don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
[Music]
go back to the cause
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
i need you to trust me right
now coming back
don't you move
okay where'd he go
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there i'm coming
with you
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
i can kill it
[Applause]
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be insane
the world needed a hero
[Applause]
it got me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one
thing wherever we go
[Music]
this family
[Music]
here's our fortress
[Music]
have you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
[Music]
you ready john
[Music]
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're going to
have fun tonight
let me guess another i.t conference i'm
going to be back in a couple days
thompson hey mom dad has a work
emergency so can you come pick me up i
love it when you call me mom lester a
rager
what's happening
please don't touch
[Music]
this is so tight
it's some kind of superhero lair your
dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step step step into the spotlight check
this out
i have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's attack before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right
yes
playtime's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
hold on
things are warm yeah so hot you got the
winter suit
[Music]
an evil is coming
that threatens our kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not prepared for
[Music]
my king the europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop until the whole of
africa is theirs
we must fight back
for our people
you are asking me to take them to war
[Applause]
some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
you are called to join the king's garden
no kingdom in all of africa shares this
privilege
train hard fight harder
we fear no one
and we fear no pain
i offer you a choice
fight
or we die
ready
[Music]
freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
bella so good to see you i'm sorry it's
under such terrible circumstances yeah
it's fine when your father passed he
left you something
very funny is that a jerk no
congratulations you have a boat right i
have a part
cheers cheers
i know a place we can go
hey no one's supposed to be out here
get your hands up
[Music]
wake up the parts moving
four mechanical locks
if we get through all those
we saw the biometric lock we gotta get
off this one
on three
[Music]
push the red button
[Music]
kill her
hope for an easy and painless death
targeting flyer
where did it go wrong he stole my part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a crooked federal agent helping
a sex trafficker smuggle women into the
country but he's watching our every move
bets are 30 minutes out we need to move
now
someone tipped them off
place is empty our resources are
compromised sneaking these women in is a
lot easier if you have a border patrol
chief in your pocket have you lost your
mind you don't just arrest him on a
hunch it was more than a hunt shut up
stay in your lane sergeant there are
protocols
i am so happy to find you alive they
killed everyone but me and now they want
me dead because i can identify every
last one of them
look the other way
this isn't as forgiveness not permission
situation
what are you suggesting
we'll see our old friends
what do you want
we need you
they need your help so that these
animals can't do it to another group of
girls
what's the plan
we need anything you can find on the
location date time where and when
they're bringing a text thread with an
address to a shipping yard shipping
container id etc will that do i never
show off aren't you okay
let's get to work
i don't have to look the other way i've
got nothing to lose
ready or not
here i come
just breathe
[Music]
uh
[Music]
right
ah
[Music]
nobody moves
foreign
i need to know everybody's alive and
well
you just have to trust me
come on
[Music]
bill stock
incoming
we met a deal
you broke it
[Music]
you